Hi everybody. My name is Laura Pearl and I
am the head of safeguarding at Newton Abbott
College. Newton Abbott College have worked
incredibly closely with the community safety
partnership for a number of years, on a number
of projects, however most recently we have been
working with them to address the anti-social
behaviour within town and the surrounding areas.
Working closely has meant that we have been
able to quickly identify individuals and
also groups of students that have caused
disruption in town and we have been able
to name those young people, address their
behaviours, and also work with them within
school and work with their parents as
well to try and disrupt behaviours.
The work that we have continued to do has had a
real positive effect on students walking to and
from school, in regards to them feeling safe
and I would encourage everybody to continue
to report anti-social behaviour that they see in
order to continue the work that we've been doing